it seems like every year there's a real
threat of a government shutdown
lawmakers racing to reach a Neo to avoid
a government shutdown and 2023 is no
different Saturday 11 59 PM deadline to
avoid a government shutdown here's why
the government is constantly on the
verge of a shutdown
for starters the US is the only country
that even can shut down everywhere else
if a government agency doesn't have a
budget for the new fiscal year they just
used last year's and keep working but
because 150 years ago a bunch of U.S
agencies would blow through their entire
budget or Appropriations in a few months
Congress passed the anti-deficiency ACT
saying it wasn't lawful to spend any sum
in excess of Appropriations made by
Congress for that fiscal year basically
if Congress doesn't pass a new funding
bill every year agencies can't spend a
dime and shut down but why that keeps
threatening to happen a century later
comes down to Congress for one these
spending bills are kind of their big
thing the one thing that Congress has to
do with the president
is write the bills to keep the
government open and working there are a
lot of measures that should be done or
could be done
but this is the be-all end-all of must
pass so these spending bills end up
becoming a vessel for all kinds of other
things like last year's sure it funded
things like the Department of
Agriculture and energy in the Department
of Defense but it also created the
Alaska salmon research task force
renamed a bunch of post offices and
change policy on the protection of
whales in the North Atlantic which
environmental activists were adamantly
opposed to other things are going to
catch a ride and that's sort of the
reality of living in a world where
Congress struggles to legislate she
isn't exaggerating this is the number of
laws that each session of Congress has
enacted not only is Congress trending
towards fewer and fewer laws but so far
this session they're off to a really
slow start they're on Pace to not even
create a hundred if there's so few
things that make it to the floor it's
the target it's your opportunity to make
a stand it makes it harder and harder to
reach those agreements in the first
place
in theory they should be reaching those
agreements with something called a
budget resolution by about mid-april but
that hasn't happened in 20 years then
they're supposed to pass those spending
bills by the new fiscal year deadline
October 1st here's how many spending
bills have been passed by then it's been
26 years since all of them were done on
time
they usually pass a short-term stop Gap
funding bill or a continuing resolution
to fund the government for just a little
bit and that's why it's seemingly that
we come back in December quite
frequently and that's when the rubber
hits the road for actually compiling all
these final decisions on spending bills
the ideological divide in Congress is
growing Republicans are more
conservative Democrats are more liberal
and then there's few members who meet
somewhere in the middle polarization
exacerbates difficulties in the process
here you can see it in Split districts
too where voters elected a
representative from one party and voted
the opposite party for president
today Congress is one of the fewest
numbers of split districts in the last
hundred years it reinforces partisanship
it makes it harder to reach final
agreements where you have to reach
across the party line and it creates an
incentive for speakers like McCarthy
never to want to deal with the Democrats
but to deliver on behalf of his party's
conference not on behalf of what the
Democrats want
so a disorganized budget process plus a
lack of opportunity to debate things
plus a lack of motivation to compromise
on those things means funding the
government is unsurprisingly a battle
look I'm working everything we can to
make sure this doesn't happen
foreign